en russie le deuil après la fusillade
hier à l'université de perm à l'est de
moscou vladimir poutine a exprimé ses
condoléances aux familles des victimes
on fait le point avec notre
correspondante sur place virago final
une grande tragédie pour toutes les
russies le président russe a réagi à la
fusillade qui a eu lieu lundi matin dans
une université de perm la dîmière
poutine a exprimé ses condoléances et
promis une enquête approfondie à propos
de ces tragédies
ma chute
je voudrais commencer par exprimer mes
condoléances en raison de la tragédie
qui a eu lieu à perm aujourd'hui
chirurgien
et remy
les forces de l'ordre feront tout pour
enquêter sur ce crime atroce pour
identifier les raisons de ce qui s'est
passé
et les autorités régionales et fédérales
prendrons toutes les mesures nécessaires
pour soutenir les blessés et les
familles des victimes
s'il n'est pas kircheisen
le ministre de la santé a écrit un
ouvrage qui a été dépêché sur place l'a
rendu compte à la presse de l'état des
personnes hospitalisées
écoutez
votre soutien
sur les 20 personnes hospitalisées neuf
sont dans un état grave elle continue de
recevoir une assistance médicale y
compris de la part des spécialistes des
cliniques fédéral qui sont arrivés et
qu'ils interviennent au bloc opératoire
et prennent part aux opérations de
réanimation rassemble en son honneur
[Musique]
le tireur un étudiants de cette
université a ouvert le feu dans
l'établissement selon les autorités il
était également en possession d'armes
l'assaillant âgé de 18 ans a été arrêté
blessé lors de son arrestation
étant donné qu'ils opposaient une
résistance avant d'être prise en charge
à l'hôpital
selon certaines sources le suspect
serait un réanimation le comité
d'enquêté a déjà mené des perquisitions
à son domicile et à interroger sa mère